bonjour madame la ministre bonjour
madame alors vous êtes en visite à
Abidjan pour une durée de deux jours
c'est votre première visite officielle
depuis que vous êtes nommé sur le
continent pourquoi la Côte d'Ivoire
d'abord j'ai un grand plaisir à
retrouver Abidjan où j'étais venu dans
le passé mais il y a trop longtemps et
donc en effet dans mes fonctions c'est
la première fois qu'en tant que ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
j'ai le plaisir d'être ici pourquoi je
suis venue mais tout simplement parce
que la Côte d'Ivoire est un pays
important de la région ça n'est pas vous
que je vais le dire et parce que c'est
un partenaire important pour la France
sur beaucoup d'aspects dont on peut
parler mais j'ai été reçu par le
président Ouattara j'ai également été
reçu par le ministre de la Défense j'ai
participé à d'autres réunions je reviens
de Yopougon parce que j'ai voulu aller à
la rencontre de jeunes et écouter aussi
parce que la jeunesse avait à nous dire
et si je dis que nous sommes un
partenaire important c'est parce que
c'est dans la durée aussi bien dans le
partenariat économique que nous avons
avec des entreprises avec une politique
de partenariat que nous rénovons que
dans des secteurs nouveaux ou nous
voulons coopérer en particulier en
regardant tout ce que nous pouvons faire
de plus pour répondre aux besoins du
pays en matière culturelle en matière
d'innovation en matière aussi
d'agriculture ou une partie de nos
actions va être réorienté sur des
actions concrètes en fonction des
besoins que le pays exprimera auprès de
Nous parmi les nombreux sujets sur la
table il y a les conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine et la question
alimentaire qui affecte toute l'Afrique
que peut faire la France concrètement
sur ce dossier
vous savez la guerre que la Russie a
choisi d'engager en Ukraine et continue
de mener depuis maintenant 10 mois elle
a des conséquences négatives pour le
monde entier évidemment au premier chef
ça concerne l'Ukraine et le peuple
craignant c'est aussi sur le continent
européen le retour d'une guerre une
guerre qui est cruelle et qui dure mais
il y a des conséquences économiques pour
l'ensemble des pays du monde évidemment
pour l'Afrique mais même dans nos pays
on voit partout les prix de l'énergie
montée une insécurité alimentaire qui
dans le monde entier est l'une des
conséquences de la guerre faite par la
Russie à l'Ukraine et ça nous préoccupe
mais nous ne sommes pas inactifs le
présent de la République a pris un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui
désormais sont portées par le G7 et par
l'Union européenne pour permettre que
les pays africains reçoivent ce dont ils
ont besoin et j'aurais parlé très
rapidement de quelques-unes de ces
initiatives d'abord il y a ce que l'on
appelle farm qui est un acronyme anglais
pour
food culture
nous aidons via les organisations
internationales que sont le FIDA le PAM
et la FAO est-ce que les marchés
mondiaux agricoles restent transparent
que les informations
puissent s'échanger de façon à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de sur la part des
sur les marchés mondiaux de la part des
différents acteurs
de comportements anormaux il faut
continuer d'entretenir les flux
commerciaux normaux la deuxième ligne
d'action le deuxième pilier si vous
voulez de Farme consiste à permettre
l'accès à des prix raisonnables pour les
pays les plus vulnérables ceux qui en
ont besoin a priorité j'ai bien appris
raisonnable et la sélection du PAM et
enfin nous aidons et tout ceci nous le
co-finançons avec nos partenaires nous
aidons à la résilience des agricultures
qui sont les plus affectés aujourd'hui
qui doivent orienter leur production de
façon peut-être moins
exposé au flux d'importation
d'exportation de la part des pays de la
région de façon à consolider leur base
agricole
la guerre que la Russie mène en Ukraine
elle a des conséquences négatives sur
tous les pays de la planète et il est
temps il est important que tous nous
nous
rassemblions pour porter ce message à la
Russie que ça suffit ce qu'elle fait
fait du tort à trop de pays sous toutes
les latitudes et qu'il faut maintenant
qu'elle est un autre comportement
d'accord là on a parlé d'insécurité
alimentaire je vais parler d'insécurité
en général les groupes terroristes
gagnent du terrain sur le continent on
constate des coups d'État au Mali au
Burkina en Guinée la Côte d'Ivoire pour
l'instant semble être épargné mais
est-ce que vous êtes inquiète pour la
stabilité dans la région alors dans la
région avec quelques pays que vous venez
de citer nous avons dû malheureusement
constater tout à la fois qu'il y a des
coups d'État et parfois des coups d'État
à répétition c'était le cas en
particulier au Mali et avec comme
conséquence une incapacité des nouvelles
autorités à faire ce qu'elles avaient
promis de faire à leur population quand
elle trahissent les besoins de sécurité
puisque on voit que les groupes
terroristes ou les groupes armés
progressent que l'instabilité s'installe
dans ces pays et qui plus est que les
autorités issues du double coup d'État
au Mali ont dû faire recours à des
mercenaires à des milices russes Wagner
pour les nommer qui non seulement sont
d'une très grande
inefficacité pour lutter contre
les mouvements terroristes mais qui
elle-même commettent des exections sur
les populations donc c'est le pire des
mondes et on a une jante qui s'enferme
sur elle-même et qui devient prisonnière
d'un groupe de mercenaires étrangers qui
n'est pas inspiré de bonnes intentions
croyez moi donc nous ne souhaitons pas
que le même schéma se reproduise au
Burkina Faso mais nous appelons à la
vigilance sur ce point parce que ce qui
s'est passé au Burkina Faso avec
l'apparition spontanée de drapeau russe
doit nous interpeller les uns les autres
je ne crois pas que la population
de façon naturelle en soi venue à penser
que la Russie allait lutter contre les
djihadistes ça n'est pas le cas c'est
faux alors justement en parlant de
population en toile de fond il y a un
sentiment anti-français qui se propage
pour vous quelles sont les causes et
pensez-vous que la Russie joue un rôle
important
je le pense je vais commencer par la fin
de votre question donc j'y réponds
directement je serai plus nuancée sur
la première formulation
qui a été la vôtre je crois qu'il faut
distinguer le discours anti-français de
la réalité et le discours anti-français
qui est véhiculé par un certain nombre
de forces que l'on voit à l'oeuvre et
parfois sur plusieurs années dans
plusieurs pays vise précisément à ancrer
un sentiment anti-français mais le
sentiment qui peut se diffuser n'est que
la résultante d'actions de
désinformation de contre-vérité de
propagande et de manipulation et lorsque
nous dénonçons et nous le faisons le
présent de la République l'a fait
lorsqu'elle était venue en terre
africaine cet été vous vous en souvenez
je le fais à cette suite lorsque nous
dénonçons les agissements de la Russie
c'est parce que nous avons des raisons
de le faire tout ceci est documenté il y
a
on va dire des contre-vérités on peut
dire avancer des mensonges et
toute manipulation laisse toujours un
effet négatif mais j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de la jeunesse de ne pas
se laisser entraîner et de ne pas
devenir prisonnière de ceux qui veulent
la manipuler ça ne doit pas réussir
parce que à la clé il y a la stabilité
la sécurité et donc le progrès la
postérité pour ces pays
donc pour vous la solution pour lutter
contre ça c'est de lutter contre la
désinformation c'est ce qu'on a compris
les solutions sont multiples évidemment
qu'il faut répondre quand il y a des
mensonges et rétablir la vérité et des
faits parce qu'on entend des choses qui
sont tellement loin de la réalité que
c'est hallucinant même que certains
puissent considérer qu'il faille le
raccorder de l'intention mais au-delà de
ça il faut bien sûr qu'il y ait des pays
organisés qui est de la bonne
gouvernance et que ces pays soient à
même de continuer leur trajectoire
d'émergence comme c'est le cas en Côte
d'Ivoire depuis une dizaine d'années la
Côte d'Ivoire va mieux ses performances
économiques sont bonnes et l'enjeu
maintenant et de tout à la fois garder
cette dynamique de progrès et bien sûr
de mieux diffuser dans l'ensemble du
pays dans toutes les couches sociales et
pas seulement de leur des couches
privilégiées et pas seulement dans des
régions plus favorisées permet aussi
dans toutes les régions du pays diffuser
cette dynamique de développement qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui l'émergence et nous
sommes là avec d'autres partenaires pour
aider la Côte d'Ivoire à continuer ses
progrès remarquables qui ont été faits
depuis 10 ans d'accord en parlant de
partenaires début novembre le président
français Emmanuel Macron après avoir
annoncé la fin de l'opération Barca
anomalie a annoncé l'ouverture de
discussions sur des nouvelles stratégies
militaires en Afrique avec quel
partenaire la France compte-t-elle
travailler en priorité la Côte d'Ivoire
le Niger ou le Tchad qui connaît aussi
une instabilité politique depuis un
moment alors le président de la
République dans un discours qu'on
appelle un discours de doctrine a mis à
jour la doctrine de défense française et
ça ne concerne pas que l'Afrique vous
l'avez vu c'est un discours de portée
générale mais avec une déclinaison
africaine et vous avez raison nous avons
engagé avec l'ensemble des partenaires
africains avec lesquels nous avons une
coopération en matière de défense et de
sécurité une réflexion
sur la façon d'assurer
aussi bien sinon mieux l'émission de
sécurité que aujourd'hui en partenariat
nous avons avec ces différents pays mais
en étant
visiblement
plus au côté de ces pays à leurs côtés
n'ont pas devant eux je ne dis pas
derrière eux mais en accompagnement et
en montrant clairement que nous avons
des actions de coopération qui
correspondent aux vœux d'ailleurs de nos
partenaires mais que nous devons mener
en pensant dans la durée que nous sommes
là pour répondre à des besoins de
sécurité pour répondre à des besoins de
formation la Côte d'Ivoire a accueilli
c'est un grand succès je crois
l'Académie internationale de lutte
contre le terrorisme des actions que
nous voulons développer de formation
d'aide en matériel d'échanges de
renseignements de lutte aussi contre des
actions de piraterie et de trafic dans
le domaine maritime des choses que nous
devons bâtir dans la durée mais au plus
près du terrain au plus près des vœux de
ces pays donc nous avons engagé une
phase de conversation qui doit durer le
président de la République l'a dit six
mois si nous pouvons nous prenons le
temps de la concertation pour voir
comment répondre aux nouveaux défis
d'une façon qui soit adaptée efficace et
nous permet d'être là dans la durée aux
côtés de nos partenaires merci Madame
madame la ministre merci beaucoup